so i have this question in my mind
though
let's say that we you know just the
thought experiment suppose that we
hadn't
done the mass vaccination
campaign yeah right and then there's
sort of two versions of that okay let's
say we did nothing and we just
behavioral modifications and nothing
else what would the world look like
today how much loss of life would there
have been and then the second version of
it the one that i would favor and i
think you would favor
is
without the vaccination program and the
aggressive development of protocols
based largely around interventions that
are known to work supplementing vitamin
d for people who are deficient
reproductive drugs absolutely early
treatments hydroxychloroquine iron any
other stuff that seems to be so
effective
where would we be today if we had done
the a and b versions of the don't don't
use these vaccines what do you think
well first of all for me it's it's you
know i i cannot i can simply not imagine
because people are always saying yeah
you're saying stop mass vaccination what
would you do you know let people die no
of course not we have these you know
treatments and it's not that these
treatments were new uh some people have
started early on like peter mccullough
etc showing that this was really very
effective and as you know i i'm coming
from the veterinary field what you often
what what you sometimes do with certain
diseases you would infect the animal
deliberately
and then you would treat the animal
so in that way you can immunize
so if somebody in other words gets the
disease
and you do the early treatment of course
also with the animal you will not wait
till till it it's it's murrabunt right
so you will treat
then this you know they will recover
from the disease automatically they will
build antibodies they will contribute to
herd immunity right and of course is
also this thing about you know all the
other age groups i mean
you know the elderly of course they we
would have had to intervene also people
with underlying diseases
comorbidities we know the groups the
vulnerable groups
all the other age groups i mean of
course they could have had some
asymptomatic some mild or moderate
disease but what is wrong with getting
the disease and being in bed for a
couple of days right we
you recover from this
it then
provides a large part of the population
with immunity with herd immunity once
this hurt immunity is established it
means that the likelihood that somebody
who is vulnerable who has a weak
innate a weak immune system
gets infected with a viral load that
would be sufficient to make that person
ill is very very remote in other terms
once you reach that third immunity
you don't you can you can just you know
skip all the infection prevention
measures etc that you had put in place
during the time where hurt immunity was
in the process of being built up in
order to protect these people right that
is what would
would some people have died of course
right but the pandemic you know i mean i
can only that's also something which is
very stunning to me astonishing that
if you are confronted with a pandemic i
mean our generation has never seen this
the first thing to do is you look what
happened in history you know what
happened with the spanish flu for
example how long did that last i've been
checking all the pandemics that have
been documented none of them lasted
longer than 18 months for example right
so and and some of them you know eight
or ten months now you have to realize
back in those days you know the the
world was still a very large
place it took time you know because
people you know were not that
interconnected etc now but now the world
has become a very small place so i even
suspect that
absolutely absolutely right so this this
this matches this matches my
sense of where we'd be if we had done
nothing
it would have there would have been a
massive loss of life it would have
it would have burned itself out and we
would be lamenting the loss of life but
we'd be effectively done with it if we
had done the right thing which is to
skip the transfection campaign
and to aggressively use the tools that
quickly became apparent that they worked
for the vulnerable population yeah yes
well
really i mean we've seen examples where
these things have been deployed well
like uttar pradesh for example yeah
probably japan although it's a little
harder to figure out what they don't
japan we can discuss this but i have uh
you guys
very i have a lot of uh very
uh strong information you know stressful
trustworthy information from really
insiders curious it's not ever making
them
about uh you know the uh
tb uh vaccine still being part of the
childhood vaccination program
and you have heard about these studies
where you know a lot of immunity gets
stimulated by the tb vaccine and and
they are saying it's rather due to this
to this fact rather than to the eye for
me but okay but anyway yeah put that
aside for the moment so
if we had treated aggressively
protected the vulnerable
prophylactically maybe we protected
everybody prophylactically in light of
the uh fact that ivermectin worked that
way in at least the initial variance i
mean one of the things that troubles me
here is that ivermectin's efficacy has
dropped right i actually didn't expect
that but it did since
when did it drop delta
delta yeah and omicron right yeah so i
think i have an explanation for this but
we can come back to this but you you can
keep it in mind yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
uh i'm very curious i don't know why you
are interested yeah but uh okay but um
but in any case i do think that we have
these two other scenarios both of them
are better than where we are
we had we've had very high loss of life
and we've had uh
basically a um
a collapse in
our belief in our medical apparatus
because it has revealed itself to be
incompetent at protecting us and it has
revealed that it's willing to lie
egregiously in all of this so yeah all
the collateral damage and bread it's not
finished well and it's not finished
which is really conspicuous because
and this this has been bugging me for
for a year now which is you know we look
at these rates right and you know the
rate is rising it's rising in a
population more than half of which has
already had the virus so the point is we
are not seeing the accumulation of the
immunity that would normally be
accompanying anything like this and
we're seeing such rapid proliferation of
these variants you know and we're seeing
people get the disease multiple times
within months of each other
there's a lot here that's non-standard
and um
you know we will of course never know
what would have happened if we had
behaved in one of these other ways but
i'm i'm
uh i'm reassured to hear that you you
see something of the same picture
absolutely
[Music]